good morning belief nation today's
message is know your strengths and
weaknesses
over to you Garry Kasparov TV go it's
very important and I also come back to
chess to learn how to recognize your own
strengths and weaknesses this is in fact
the vital part of preparation for a big
match and for anything in life we always
try to study our opponents we always try
to try to study the battlefield we
always try to study all the
circumstances surrounding our venture
endeavor but very often we forget to
study ourself and this is very important
because any choice of a ground for
battle or you know type of strategy we
want to employ depends on our
recognition of our strengths and
weaknesses and this is a process of
constant evaluation because life is
changing very fast and our opponents
looking at our success studying it and
trying to be to be smart and outsmart us
eventually and we can look at the
history and just to find a number of
situations where the the inability to
recognize strengths and weaknesses led
to an eventual disaster so where you
think I think when you know your
strengths and weaknesses you spend time
doing what you should be doing and not
wasting time doing things that you
shouldn't be doing I think there's so
much that you have to get done in a
company that you end up spending 90% of
your time doing stuff that really
shouldn't be done by you and only 10% of
your time doing like the CEO big-picture
stuff I think as soon as you can look at
how can i maybe eliminate some of the
tasks that I'm doing that aren't
relevant that are going to help me I
think we do things that we shouldn't
even doing at all and then how can you
automate things and how can you delegate
the first person I hired was for one
hour a day so that one hour saved me a
little bit over an hour so I can focus
on bigger picture things and so if you
are continually doing projects that
you're not great at
and you're never going to accomplish
anything great with your business so as
soon as possible it's figuring out what
you're really good at focusing only on
that going all-in on your strengths and
then surround yourself with people who
can help them with your weaknesses so
the question of the day today is what is
the one thing that you can identify as
your weakness you need to drop right
away move I like that one
leave it in the comments below we're
going to both join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and
you'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso that was
okay and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot hahaha for
another shot of espresso for another
shot of espresso shot the shot punch
oven spresso oh man for another shot of
espresso I did it to my time shot it's a
shot natural thus a shot shot of shot of
espresso shine together Jim this is the
hardest part for another shot of
espresso espresso that is messed up I
said and spread oh you said Express of
espresso what's the subject again see
now you're gonna direct me are you well
it's just a little better I'm okay i
read about the fans of rain that's not a
problem
don't that me place already know your
strengths do we know your strengths and
weaknesses okay
strengths and weaknesses you got
something no oh good expresso give me go